So do you think we're alone in the universe?
Are we the only intelligent life?
No.
I think there probably are many different kinds of life forms, a thousand organisms.
Some may not be visible, some may not have been discovered...
...and some may be on places we can't go.
And they all might have the same perspective as we do on this:...
...that there might be others and that maybe they can find them someday.
But at the moment they don't know.
They're part of a big world.
Well, what do you think about the idea of alternate universes?
I think it's realistic at the same time as it is fantasy.
That's exactly what scientists think.
They're not sure, they have the math to prove it...
...but they haven't observed it so they don't know.
Yeah, it's just very complicated...
...because you have no proof that there's anything out there.
The only proof is yourself.
Right.
And where you are in the universe.
And you can only make theories, you can never know the truth.
So what's the meaning of our lives here on Earth then?
That's one of the hardest questions there is.
I would say what the meaning of your life is, is what you make it.
What you think, what you want your life to be.
Nobody can decide what you will do except for you.